so why is potassium the most important
electrolyte that's the question for
today well let's just take a look at
four main electrolytes we have k plus
which is the chemical symbol for
potassium we need 4 700 milligrams then
we have sodium which is n a plus
1500 to 2300 milligrams then we have
calcium ca
we need a thousand milligrams and the
magnesium
we only need 420 milligrams so we can
see that we need 10 times as much
potassium than we do magnesium then with
sodium we need twice as much potassium
and with calcium we need four times as
much so why do we need so much potassium
well first of all what is an electrolyte
electrolyte is an electrically charged
mineral when you take an electrolyte and
you put it in water it separates and
becomes conductive to electricity so our
bodies use electrolytes for various
things to help conduct nerve impulses to
help you contract and relax muscles to
help maintain ph in the body as well as
to help push fluid through the body
thirty percent of all the energy
in our body
comes from this little pump called the
sodium potassium pump but i do have to
say that the definition for pump is
slightly different than the pump that
you probably have down in your basement
as the sump pump this is a biological
definition it means the mechanism for
movement of electrolytes through the
cell membrane okay so that's a little
bit different than just a pump pushing
fluid somewhere so 30 of all the energy
that you have whether it's digesting or
thinking et cetera thirty percent of all
the energy comes from this sodium
potassium pump so the purpose of this
pump is to basically keep sodium out and
keep potassium in so it's keeping these
two minerals separated okay that's the
purpose of this pump anytime you have
two different minerals which are
electrically charged in a different way
okay you form a battery
so with a battery you have a positive
and a negative there's a difference in
this electrical charge and that allows
for energy to be maintained for the
purpose of this pump is to maintain
cellular energy so your cells are
basically
batteries
and the battery is there to help
generate nerve impulses
which happen to be connected to muscles
so it's activating the muscles you have
electrical impulses that are actually
changing the muscle rhythm then we need
energy to have the muscles contract and
relax and help regulate the ph of the
body and one purpose of that is to allow
enzymes to work so for example there are
certain enzymes that actually work in
different phs so
if your digestive system is the wrong ph
that enzyme won't work let's take the
stomach for example you have this
extremely powerful
protein enzyme called peptase right and
that enzyme is activated when the
stomach reaches a certain ph level if
the stomach never reaches that ph level
and then the enzyme never becomes
activated and then you don't digest
protein so the ph is very very important
and the stomach is greatly dependent on
potassium
for its ph and its ability to digest
protein all right and then we have fluid
balance if you don't have enough
potassium guess what your ankles are
going to swell up with fluid sometimes
when you see people with sandals they
have this
these indentations around the sandals
where they have this all this puffy
fluid and i just want to walk up to them
and tell them just take some potassium
all that fluid will completely go away
probably within a few hours but i have
to withhold myself from doing that
because sometimes people consider that
rude all right so what does potassium do
well it keeps us
energetic okay it gives us endurance
when we exercise if you're low in
potassium you will not be able to go as
far when you exercise
it also prevents cramping like the
cramps that you get in your calves or
your feet now it could also be magnesium
as well also potassium is necessary to
prevent arrhythmias okay which is part
of the pacemaker of your heart
it also helps prevent twitching
tremors
constipation because you have this it's
called peristalsis this pumping action
through your colon which is controlled
by the nervous system and the muscular
system so without potassium you don't
get this pumping action through the
colon and things just kind of sit there
also potassium is necessary to prevent
vascular calcification
so potassium is definitely needed in the
regulation of calcium now without
potassium you get insomnia you can't
sleep so potassium is a physiological
tranquilizer it relaxes the body much
like magnesium does so let's just say
for example you're deficient in
potassium for some reason you're going
to lay there on the pillow and try to
get to sleep but your heart's going to
be pounding
faster
you're going to feel your muscles more
tense
you're not going to be able to get into
that relaxed state all right the next
thing is insulin resistance i have a lot
of videos on this topic
potassium is needed to prevent insulin
resistance in fact if you take a
diabetic or a pre-diabetic or someone
with insulin resistance they're always
deficient in potassium so potassium will
help your blood sugars it will help
lessen this insulin resistance and
insulin in the cell allows certain
nutrients to go inside and fuel so
anything that inhibits this insulin
function
stops the absorption of nutrients and
fuel into the cells so this is just
another reason why potassium is
important in blood sugars now you also
have stored glucose that's called
glycogen glycogen is a string of glucose
molecules which also have with it a
string of potassium molecules so in
order for glucose to be stored in the
liver and the muscle you also need
potassium and without the potassium you
don't store glycogen as well and so if
you don't store glycogen the body then
starts storing more fat instead of
stored sugar and so potassium is
involved in a lot of different aspects
of your blood sugars when you go on the
ketogenic diet
the requirement for this glycogen goes
down so you're not going to need to
store as much glycogen the same thing
goes with when you do intermittent
fasting so you're not eating so your
body is then running on ketones so
you're not running on glucose so you
don't need as much of this
so this kind of goes away so you're
basically burning it up and it's not
replaced as much especially in your
liver after about one to two days and so
what happens is you're going to lose a
lot of glycogen glucose
and you're also going to lose potassium
this is why when you start on the
ketogenic diet you need to take a
potassium supplement i always recommend
one in electrolytes so you have all of
them not just potassium all right the
next thing that potassium does is it
helps to prevent high blood pressure if
someone has high blood pressure the
easiest thing to do is just to increase
the potassium and their body and it
usually will come down the other cause
of high blood pressure is low vitamin d
and then a lot of times people say well
wait a second i thought high blood
pressure was caused by high sodium okay
well you need
sodium and potassium in the right ratios
so instead of lowering sodium which by
the way you need a certain amount of
sodium for a lot of reasons why not
increase potassium because yes you might
have too much sodium but in reality you
just don't have enough potassium to deal
with that sodium so these people that
are salt sensitive usually are just
potassium deficient all right and
another common myth that i've heard is
that you don't want to take potassium
because it's very toxic to the kidney
that's false information in fact
potassium protects your kidneys unless
you have stage five
kidney failure in which case you have to
avoid a lot of different nutrients but
if you don't have end stage kidney
failure potassium is actually beneficial
for the kidneys and i'm going to put a
link down below for those people who
have not heard that information before
in fact potassium citrate
is good for preventing kidney stones
it's also good to prevent gout which is
uric acid crystals so potassium is
actually very very good for a lot of
different things
now i already mentioned this it prevents
edema okay swelling if you have swelling
usually you have an imbalance of too
much sodium and not enough potassium
when you take sufficient potassium
it's like a diuretic if you have fluid
retention you will get rid of that
excess fluid all right i already
mentioned this potassium counters sodium
toxicity
also i already mentioned that it helps
you make stomach acid and i also
mentioned it helps prevent
gout because potassium citrate is
alkaline and if you keep the the ph
correct and don't allow your ph to
become too acidic you won't have these
uric acid crystals coming out of
solution aggravating
your big toe joint all right so now the
question is why are we deficient in
potassium well the number one reason is
because of the diet the average person
only consumes about a cup and a half of
vegetables every single day okay a cup
and a half well where in food would you
get a lot of rich potassium bananas
right
well in a banana it's only 300
milligrams we need 4 700 milligrams so
if we do the math
you would need 15.6 bananas per day to
reach your
4700 requirement now
the problem with bananas is they come
with too much sugar so bananas are not
the best source the best source would be
leafy greens okay but yes you would need
at least seven to ten cups to contribute
to this amount but realize also other
food will contribute so it's not just
the salad there's even potassium in
certain things like salmon for example
and there's potassium in nuts and seeds
and nut butters and so there's other
sources of potassium but the leafy
greens have a good amount and it's
fairly easy to eat big salads now
when i say one cup i'm talking about
like a small handful which is like one
ounce so you need like a bowl of salad
you could do one for your lunch and then
you can do one for your dinner to make
it really easy but i did a video on
showing you the amount so i will put
that link down below
now avocados are loaded with potassium
one avocado is roughly about 700
sometimes 800 milligrams of potassium so
avocados are really good now i don't
recommend going out and getting a
potassium supplement unless there's a
higher amount of potassium like an
electrolyte powder because typically the
supplements for potassium only come in
99 milligrams okay so you would need
like what 47
pills every single day and that's not
very practical
so i recommend you try as much as you
can to get it from your diet or get a
good electrolyte powder that has enough
of these electrolytes
number two if you
are vomiting you're going to lose your
potassium if you have diarrhea you can
lose your potassium diuretics are
notorious for becoming potassium
deficient
i mean it's kind of wild that you're
here you are taking a drug for your high
blood pressure
when that is going to deplete your
potassium and create
a higher amount of blood pressure
doesn't make sense to me
okay stress
when you have stress you deplete your
potassium reserves and by the way when
you actually take potassium it relaxes
your nervous system it pulls you out of
this stress state
sugar depletes your potassium real quick
i have to tell this story my wife and i
years ago right right before we're
getting married
we went to shop around for um wedding
cakes okay
and we were sampling wedding cakes and
we're eating sugar all day this is
before i had any awareness on
healthy foods at all so we ended up that
night at an italian restaurant and we
had pasta pizza we had bread we had wine
we were carved out right and then we
looked up and everyone was gone in the
restaurant except us and they were
except another guy was
going past us with the dessert trays all
the different desserts they were
actually going to toss them and he
wanted to know if we wanted to sample
some before he
tossed them and of course i don't like
to see food go to waste so i started to
dive in and started consuming
as much additional dessert as i can cram
into my mouth now as i was driving home
that night i remember
i feeling kind of weird so i got home
i went to bed
tried to go to bed and i started to hear
my
this pounding in my ear just like boom
boom boom boom boom what is going on i
had no idea that was a severe potassium
deficiency caused by consuming a
tremendous amount of refined grains and
sugar
okay so all this refined grain and sugar
literally depletes you of potassium and
starts to accelerate the heart rate
my heart rate was literally going so
high my heart was pounding out of my
chest okay i didn't sleep one minute if
i would have known what i know now back
then i would have just either took some
potassium or had a big salad to try to
replenish some of this lost potassium
perfect example of low potassium all
right when you do keto you need to take
potassium because you're going to lose
fluid which you're going to then lose
potassium when you drink alcohol
you can deplete your body of potassium
when you consume excessive fluids so
some people drink gallons of fluid while
they're working out and they're sweating
too and they're losing not just their
sodium electrolyte they're also losing
their potassium so they're going to
become very dehydrated and feel dizzy
and weak and so
when you drink gallons of water you
better be drinking your electrolytes at
the same time but not just potassium
sodium too
and i mentioned this sweating right here
okay diabetes diabetics
need or require more potassium and
they're usually always deficient in
potassium because of this insulin
resistance thing
so potassium is very very important for
diabetics especially
yet they're just retaining
sodium like crazy in fluid without the
potassium all right then we have fasting
now the thing about fasting is when
you're fasting especially prolonged
fasting
sometimes uh you're not able to store
some of these electrolytes for a long
period of time so if you're deficient
you know whether it's magnesium or
potassium going into a fast
and you're not consuming anything
no electrolytes then it's exaggerated
you can feel dizzy you could pass out so
this is why when you fast i recommend
taking electrolytes all right so now
that you know about potassium
let's show you the video that i
mentioned about
consuming enough salad i put it right
here check it out